this one's personal I know what it's
like to have the government say we're
gonna kill you in the morning
I know what it's like to leave a country
on six hours a notice and land on
someone's couch because of that I wrote
a book on why countries do well in why
they don't let me summarize 250 pages
countries have to be compassionate they
have to be kind they have to be smart
they have to be brave what I know what
doesn't work when you get R in through
fear and you're going through cruelty it
just doesn't work you can play Genghis
Khan for a while you can play Stalin for
a while you can play Pinochet for a
while it does not work in the long run
and it doesn't work in the long run
because to govern through fear and
cruelty you have to create a division
you have to take big chunks of the
country and convince them they're not
like them but they shouldn't associate
with them that they shouldn't talk to
them that those people are nasty those
people are criminals those people are
rapists and the country is in danger
because of them and if you spend
millions of dollars doing that in your
country you will make enemies abroad and
you will create divisions within and
that has consequences three quarters of
the flags and the borders and the
anthems around the United Nations study
they were not there a few decades ago
those lines that are there today those
flags were created because somebody said
the Scots are not like us the Welsh are
not like us the Basques are not like us
the northern Italians are not like us
the Muslims are not like us the blacks
the whites the Christians you create us
versus them you destroy nations part of
the problem from creating us versus them
is it's hard to do what you have to do
is you have to make people believe
absurdities and once people believe
absurdities then they start to commit
that's the dynamic of this thing you
can't create us versus them you can't
have the massacres you had in Ronda you
can't have the massacres you had in us
la vía unless if you create this dynamic
let me summarize current immigration
policy
let's deter them by being as cruel as we
can possibly be and let's target their
children they are going after the
children you have us lawyers arguing
that kids do not need soap or hugs or
showers adult help a release date
somebody gets pulled over for broken
taillight who's worked here for 20 years
gets thrown into jail maybe for life
with no legal representation the
terrorists have blow up the World Trade
Center get lawyers these kids these
parents they don't get lawyers
governments are telling some of the most
desperate hurt people on earth
I took your child pay me $800 for a DNA
test before you get it back
four-year-olds are appearing in court
look we've all watched these courtroom
dramas and it's exciting because the
wise judge sits up there and the defense
lawyer attacks and the prosecutor
counter-attacks and then you figure out
how it's gonna happen I want you to
understand what is happening right now
prosecutors there it's the tough
prosecutor accusing attacking on behalf
of We the People the judge is up there
judge marketing luck with his black
robes and he's questioning the defendant
from up there and the defendant is 3
years old and the eyes don't reach the
side of the table the defendant does not
speak the language the earphones for the
translator have fallen off the
defendants head because there are no
headphones for 3 year olds in US
courtrooms because they are not supposed
to defend themselves
makes a mockery of justice and makes a
mockery the prosecution system and makes
a mockery of who we are as a nation
these are absurdities these are
atrocities this is unbelievable and
we're looking at a bunch of statistics
but I want you to understand this is
happening to the housekeeper who brought
up your kids this is happening to the
gardener who took care of your house
this is happening to the guy who washed
the dishes in the fancy restaurant you
went to last week this is happening the
people who deliver the newspaper in the
mornings this is your community these
are the people who have lived side by
side with you treated you well treated
you with respect taking care of your
kids taking care of your grandparents
this is Luis this is Laura this is Jaime
this isn't some abstract oh it's
happening at the border this is
happening in our community right now and
the danger and the stuff is once you
start normalizing absurdities and
atrocities people think that those
instruments are legitimate so you get
school board's sending out letters like
this dear parent because your kid owes
lunch money to the cafeteria the result
may be that your child will be taken
away and put in foster care this is
going out from school boards because
people think well that seems to be an
instrument of deterrence when you board
an airplane before kids before first
class soldiers in uniform board some of
them are immigrants here's the contract
join the army serve your term be
honorably discharged get citizenship we
are rescinding those contracts after
they have been signed and if those
soldiers are killed in action
we are deporting their wives and
sometimes their children these are the
people who protect us these are the
people that we honor these are the brave
and this is how we're treating them
these are not the
bull who crossed the border illegally
once you start allowing this kind of
behavior it normalizes into a society
and it rips the society apart countries
are built on the hard work and grit of
immigrants we are all immigrants we just
came at different times fifty-five
percent of this country's main
businesses the most successful business
in this country the unicorns are built
by people who came as foreign students
or who came as immigrants and they're
the founders or the co-founders well
here's what's happened over the last
three years to the best brains in the
world 42% of them did not get visas or
chose not to get visas this is how you
wipe out an economy
this isn't about kids and borders it's
about us this is about who we are who we
the people are as a nation and as
individuals this is not an abstract
debate a lot of us like to think if we
had been back when Hitler was rising to
power we would have been out in the
street we would have opposed him we
would have stopped mangal a lot of us
like to think we'd been around during
the 60s we will win with the Freedom
Riders we would have been at that bridge
in Selma but guess what
here's your chance it's now and as
you're thinking about this stuff it's
not just the giant axe it's not just go
and block the bridge or chain yourself
to something it's what you do in your
daily lives the Harvard Art Museum just
opening a show on how artists think
about immigration building a home
somewhere else and people come out of
that show and they're pretty shaken
there was a blank wall at the end and
the curators did something that usually
doesn't happen they improvised they drew
four lines and put in two words I belong
so you come out of this exhibit and you
can take a picture in front I can't tell
you the impact that has on people i
watch people come out with us and
someone sat for that
Taron took the picture and they had a
great big grin on their face and some
people just had tears some people hugged
and brought in strangers others brought
in their family small acts of kindness
go a long long long way
there is pain going on in your community
like you cannot believe
so next time you're will a cab driver
who may be one of them according to
certain people give that person extra
five bucks next time you see a hotel
maid thank her and tip her double next
time you see your gardener you see your
nanny you see some letter like let's
give them a great big hug and tell them
they belong make them feel like they
belong it's time for big policies but
it's also time for big acts of kindness
because we have to reclaim who we are we
have to reclaim this nation and we
cannot sit there and watch the [ __ ]
going on this has got a stump it's got a
stop now thank you
[Applause]
[Music]